let's see how to run a Windows container  on compute engine  first we need a Windows VM in Google  Cloud console go to the compute engine  section and create an instance make sure  Windows server for containers is  selected for the boot disk  windows Password  and use that password to RDP into the  instance now let's pull a nano server  image that includes PowerShell  and run it as a container this will take  us inside the container  create a HelloWorld PowerShell script  and exit the container get the container  ID and create a new image from the  modified container  finally create and run a container based  on the image we just created  there you go you're running a Windows  container on Google Cloud